this box has three red marbles and five
blue ones and two marbles are drawn at
random yes two marbles are drawn from
these eight what is the probability that
both of them are red we have seen a
similar example earlier pause the video
and think about how you could approach
this problem if you are confused then
that's good because there are two
possibilities here let's understand the
first one we pick one marble and then
pick another one we pick and pick what
is the second possibility we pick one
marble we place it back and then pick
another one yes pick replace pick these
are the two ways in which two marbles
can be drawn let's understand the first
one we pick one marble first what is the
probability that it is red there are
three red marbles and a total of eight
marbles so the probability of the first
marble picked being red will be three
over eight three red marbles and eight
in total now one red marble is picked
what is the probability of the second
one being red look at what's remaining
in the box
two red marbles and seven in total so we
multiply this with two over seven why
did we multiply because there is an and
here we pick and pick probability of a
and B is equal to the probability of a
multiplied by the probability of B given
a has already happened
this is the probability of picking a red
marble and this is the probability of
picking a red marble after having picked
one now let's move on to the second case
of pick replace pick what is the
probability of picking a red marble
first three red ones out of a total of
eight three over eight now that the red
marble is put back in what is the
probability of picking a red marble
again it's the same
three red marbles out of a total of
eight marbles three over eight we can
clearly see the difference in the first
case the second event is dependent on
the first one and in the second case the
second event is independent of the first
one now some of you might be wondering
about the third case of picking two
marbles simultaneously just think about
it for a moment
won't it be the same as the first case
but can pick without replacement picking
two marbles simultaneously might look
different from picking two marbles one
after the other but the outcome will be
the same this will be the probability
for both so we can write simultaneously
under pick and pick they are essentially
the same now if you have studied
permutations and combinations there is
another way in which we can look at this
probability we have to find the
numerator and the denominator the
denominator will have all the possible
outcomes picking any two out of the
possible eight it will be selecting any
two out of eight hc2 and in the
numerator we will have all the favorable
outcomes as both have to be red they
have to be selected from these three red
ones only selecting two out of three or
three see - this will also give us three
over twenty eight as the probability
which is the same as this one
so unless specifically mentioned these
are the two cases we have to consider
when two things are to be picked from a
set of n things with the same data given
what would be the probability of both
marbles being drawn being of the same
color we will see the solution in the
next part of the session